and the city of north las vegas is  ramping up its vaccination efforts  earlier today the first drive-through  vaccination clinic was held at the north  las vegas city hall  more than 500 doses of the johnson and  johnson vaccine were administered  local leaders say the clinic served both  walk-ins and people with scheduled  appointments  to make things as convenient as possible  this is just another one of our efforts  to reach our community  we want to make it as convenient as we  can for folks to get their vaccinations  it makes me feel extremely good it's  like that blanket of comfort once you  have that shot  and then you're able to do more with  your families than you could before  it's an opportunity to get folks the the  vaccine that they want  and that they they need to stay healthy  north las vegas has appointments  available at the csn north las vegas  location  you can find the link on our website  8newsnow.com